[Music]
hello and welcome to the view from 22
I'm Kate Andrews Spectators economics
editor and I'm joined by Marian tupy who
is the editor at humanprogress.org a
senior fellow at the Kato Institute and
author of super abundance Maran thanks
for joining me on the view from 22 the
Crux of your argument is that we will
never run out of resources that is a
counter tude of arent why are you so
convinced by it well partly because we
have never run out of anything um and uh
partly because we already know how to
increase the supply of resources to keep
up with population and consumption
growth uh we know how to increase
efficiencies so that we use less
resources in order to achieve certain
outcome uh we know that we can have
substitution uh meaning that instead of
for example killing uh whales in order
to get their um fat um for oil lamps uh
we now use electricity so we can we can
increase efficiency we can um we can
substitute we can reuse so right now all
that uh all that zinc and all that
copper is temporarily assigned to do
certain functions but in the future we
can still reuse them to do something
else after all uh the same amount of
resources that were always on the planet
are still here they haven't
disappeared um dematerialization is
going on which means that your iPhone uh
is uh also a radio a TV a phone a
notebook etc etc so we are using less
resources um that way um and and should
at some point in the future come a
moment when we really don't have
resources then we can create our own
resources um all you need to create new
elements is uh Fusion reactors and
hydrogen so there's an
infinite way of infinite number of
possibilities how we can incre increase
our uh resource Supply and therefore
continue to feed Humanity the pandemic
sent out mi mix messages on this as did
Russia's war against Ukraine because on
the one hand we did have shortages we
have had shortages around all kinds of
things including medical supplies during
Co certainly around petrol and oil uh
since Russia decided to invade Ukraine
on the flip side of that most people
certainly in the UK in the US where you
live uh they won't have felt those
limitations because people quickly
compensated other Supply chains got
online some will say that is a reason
that we need to homeg grow everything
that is the reason we actually need to
throw away these Supply chains and make
sure everything is available in our
country other say no this is this is
capitalism at work this is an incredible
story I suspect you fall into the ladder
camp but is there some Merit in that
first Camp of saying look these things
can break down we have to be prepared
well the key point of the book and of my
work is that there is nothing inherent
on the planet to prevent us from having
more resources from creating more
resources in fact what we found was that
in spite of us using a lot of res
resources to power the Industrial
Revolution over the last 200 years
resources today are much cheaper than
what they were uh for our ancestors so
there's nothing inherent on the planet
preventing us from doing that but uh of
course politics can interfere Wars can
interfere they can make resources
artificially scarcer uh because we bomb
factories or we put um uh barriers to
trade we blockade each other and what
have you um and uh that's exactly what
happened when coid created an artificial
shortage or rather government response
to co has created artificial shortages
and then of course the war in Ukraine
the the Russian invasion of Ukraine has
reminded us of the importance of Peace
if you want to have plenty um you you
you it's best if the world is at peace
now um I think that globalization will
undergo certain adjustments uh
people will more likely most likely be
interested in for example having more uh
pharmaceutical companies producing drugs
at home uh there will be some
adjustments in terms of uh Supply chains
with regard to National Defense uh the
armaments industry and so on but I do
caution people from assuming that uh
autarchy is possible I don't think
autarchy is possible for Britain and and
I don't think autarchy is possible for
United States we only have 300 million
people only Yes sounds like a lot from
the UK perspective but but but when you
think about the tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of different
products that American people like to
buy that need to be sourced from the
rest of the world the avocados from
Mexico the blueberries and and and
grapes from Chile um um whiskey from
Scotland um we simply don't have enough
people to be able to create those
products at home in the United
States and to the same quality so trade
will have to continue and and trade is
also a fabulous way of ensuring that
when you do have a domestically
generated shortage you can respond to
that shortage by importing something
from abroad and a perfect example of
that was the was the astonishing failure
of providing um infant formula in the
United States uh for whatever reasons
some of them quite complicated technical
reasons um we only ended up with two
companies in the United States creating
uh invent formula and and both of those
for some reason were unable to supply
the market so at that point we had to
drop our protectionist um policies
against Europe and import infant formula
from the from Europe otherwise we would
still have shortages in in some ways uh
these Global uh links increase fragility
but in many ways they
actually create an antifragile economy
um very much depends on time and place
there's so many who would claim that the
world is now overpopulated that we have
far too many people that they'd like to
see a reduction in the number of people
who are currently on the planet but um
one of the the graphs I was looking
through your many graphs that you
provide on on human progress it's a very
optimistic tale that's told there um and
and one I was looking at was food supply
I mean it is incredible actually you
would think again it's counterintuitive
right this idea that the more people you
get the greater the food supply becomes
a lot of people make a reasonable
assumption that the graph would be going
the other way but it's not um are there
any areas where we do see a tightness
though as we have more people as we get
wealthier and can buy more things do we
see tradeoffs
elsewhere well
um I you got me on this question
um sometimes uh for ex for let's say for
example that you enjoy ocean front
property and if you have a lot of people
yes and and if you have a lot of people
and there is only so much ocean front
property to go to go around so you know
uh prices may increase uh with growth in
population obviously you're going to
have increases in the price of hous
housing in uh most desirable areas um
now we can compensate for that mhm in an
ideal world for example you can increase
um Beach uh uh property by for example
what they did in Dubai they've
created miles and miles of new beach
front properties uh on the Palm Island
and so forth so it's not true uh that U
um all of these things are restricted
you you can actually
increase those kind of shortages just as
you can increase uh housing um it is
true that housing has increased in price
in some of the very desirable areas but
if we didn't have nism if we didn't have
government overregulation we would
probably be able to um increase housing
Supply and therefore decrease the prices
of of of of housing so um I think that
within a free market economy uh the
market
adjusts to population increases
sometimes population increase can create
a temporary problem but so long as you
have a free market these things do get
sorted out but if you do have a
population
increase and the market is not allowed
to perform its magic uh the the the
Invisible Hand is not allowed to
increase the supply for example because
of government regulations then uh these
sort of artificial shortages can
continue for a long time to come um
housing is a great example it brings me
on to the next question I wanted to ask
you which is um about uh willingness to
build more willingness to create more um
here in the UK there is a housing crisis
the housing market act acts less like a
market more like a cartel it is very
difficult for young people these days
without the bank of mom and dad to even
think of a time where they might get on
the housing ladder especially
in areas like London and the southeast
where a lot of the jobs are but they're
simply not able to live um but based on
what you're saying here you know this
isn't an issue of scarcity because the
world and its laws dictate there has to
be scarcity it's a choice being made by
government yes I mean you do have a lot
of I believe you call it brown Fields
here in the United Kingdom uh where you
could build uh more houses um we have a
lot of really awful Green Belt land too
I mean you know Wasteland essentially
that gets dubbed as green belts and then
it's very very hard to claw it back yes
and uh a lot of times governments will
respond to or are responding to uh
special interest groups um pensioners
for example who uh or or property owners
who don't like to see um new buildings
uh being built in their areas and those
people are likely to vote in greater
numbers than than young people uh
without housing so so politicians
respond to those kinds of pressures um
but this is a problem across the world
and and we know it's a government
created U shortage uh only only short
while ago um young man from Australia
was complaining to me that the house
prices in Australia are very very high
and unaffordable for the young but
Australia is a continent size sized
country and it's almost totally empty so
there's absolutely no reason not to have
housing there uh but the government
stands in the way so um the bottom line
is that uh clearly the the the housing
has been there's an artificial shortage
going on uh created by uh overregulation
um at at different levels of governments
and different veto points and uh
environmentalist Etc uh but there's
nothing inherent uh which which should
prevent us from building more housing
once the political atmosphere changes
like if young people for example decide
to vote vot and protect their
interests um as I mentioned human
progress likes to tell a good story um
and we can show our viewers some of
those graphs now from economic Trends to
violence Trends to social trends so much
is going in the right direction is there
anything in the data right now anywhere
in the world that you've spotted where
you think gosh that's actually not going
in the right direction or that's not
moving fast enough sure and and part of
it has to do with uh U the government's
response to the coid uh pandemic and the
policies that we have pursued since then
uh I will speak about the United States
which is the country I know best um our
incomes per capita adjusted for
inflation are still lower than what they
were back in uh uh 2020 uh and that's
because like Britain we have shut down
large sections of our economy uh we went
into a lockdown and uh then on top of
everything else we had a bout of
inflation so our incomes are still lower
on top of that in the United States uh
we have a problem with decreasing life
expectancy this is something which has
happened in the United States before I
think there was one period when two
years in succession life expectancy was
falling but in the United States right
now I think for three years consecutive
years we've had a fall in life
expectance now part of it was driven by
coid but part of it is also driven by
the opioid epidemic oh wow I mean so so
that's obviously very regrettable
certainly I think it's understood here
in the UK that that is a serious crisis
in America
uh but a lot of that gets lumped into
the War on Drugs can you talk a little
bit more about the opioid crisis and and
just how disastrous it is in the US
right now well I'm not a specialist in
in this area by any means uh but we did
have a problem with
painkillers uh which which some people
believe are being too liberally
prescribed and then uh you know we had
um we had a problem with people
basically dying as a result of um uh of
um overc
consumption the other side of the
argument is of course that U um pain
colors do play a role in killing pain
and that um you know there are a lot of
patients right now who are suffering
needlessly because um luck thereof
nonetheless when we isolate the data we
can say that there is a problem in the
United States
because opioid debts are not happening
in other parts of the advanced Western
world mhm so we have a problem there on
top of that we have the problem with
fanol which is a uh brand new problem um
and I don't think that we have a handle
on on how to deal with it given how
porous the border is um in the South and
how much of fentol is actually coming to
the United States uh from from
Mexico um back to the the Crux of your
book super abundance um we've just had a
global AI Summit here in the UK hosted
by prime minister vishy sunak attended
by Elon Musk and other world leaders and
I'm curious about your perspective on AI
uh and how it relates to your thesis
around the super abundance because um I
might imagine that you're quite
optimistic and hopeful about AI that it
will be able to create all kinds of
prosperity in the ways that you're
talking about where we become more
efficient and more effective and
actually use fewer resources at least
that's the positive spin on it the the
possibility is there um but we always
have to be aware that any technology any
technology um can be used for good and
evil and that is true of AI as it is
true of nuclear power MH nuclear is a
perfect example of a technology which
can provide the world with uh Co CO2
free energy but can also be used in
nuclear weapons uh but it is also true
of a common knife which can be used in
order to provide dinner or kill someone
so any technology can be used for good
and evil and I think AI uh must be seen
like that it has the potential of
revolutionizing the entire economy um
only yesterday I was reading a story
about how good AI is at detecting
cancers much more so uh than a human
being so there are all these potential
benefits in the future as well as
potential dangers um I don't know but I
don't think that anybody knows MH how
this is going to play
out my tendency is
to be the on on the optimistic side of
things because partly because human
beings have have a psychological Quirk
whereby they're afraid of losses much
more than they are looking forward or
being appreciative of potential gains so
we have this negativity bias whereby any
new technology we always think about oh
my God what can go wrong
as opposed to how can this improve the
world a perfect example of that would be
mechanization of
Agriculture you know um how many people
were worried that uh the rise of the
tractor and um other forms of mechanized
agriculture would displace all of these
workers and you know what happened it
did in 1900 40 40% 40 40% of American
laborers worked in the agricultural
sector today it's 1 and a half% are
those workers unemployed of course not
they're just doing other things working
in other jobs that didn't exist when
agriculture was dominant so I think that
we've always been very negative very
very worried about about um um about new
technology this new technology has a
potential to revolutionize the world but
there is a non-zero chance that it might
not work out nonzero yeah and what that
non-zero look looks like it's varying
degrees of of um uh difficulty for us to
handle I suppose um are you familiar
with the concept of fully automated
luxury
communism no okay you have to explain
that to me it's an idea that I became
familiar with uh years back when a
leftwing commentator Aaron bastani made
it the title of his book uh the idea
might have been bouncing around before
that I'm not sure but uh fully automated
luxury communism is is quite a pure
Marxist idea that you use capitalism to
create this super abundance but
particularly you do it through AI you do
it through Tech and taking that to the
brink and creating as much wealth and
prosperity as you can now I'm curious I
I suspect that you and Aon bani would
would come to different conclusions but
how different is your thesis of the
super abundance really from this idea of
fully automated luxury communism you
know just trying to embrace the merits
of capitalism using technology to do
that and then drifting off into a Utopia
what a fabulous question I mean I I I'm
really
I'm excellent question um let me think
let me think about that so um my problem
my main problem with Communism obviously
well let's put aside the human rights
abuses but it's the central planning
right um I I I wouldn't want any kind of
central planning and I wouldn't want uh
and I and I don't think that even
AI could play a
role equivalent to Central
planning
because because we are still dealing
with unpredictable human beings so
whether I'm going to buy a cup of coffee
today a
crosson um or whether I'm going to buy
two cups of coffee and no crosson
tomorrow that still very much depends on
how I feel what I want AI cannot see
that that AI cannot predict how human
beings will interact in the marketplace
what sort of in the same way governments
can't well well that but that's what I'm
heading is that that that is why central
planning failed
because no government had enough
knowledge we are now talking about the
high knowledge problem they no
government ever had the kind of insight
to know whether what people wanted next
year was short skirts or short sleeved
shirts uh or long sleeved shirts just
didn't know right you couldn't predict
it is not clear to me how AI could ever
predict the future um in in that kind of
way and therefore centrally plann the
economy to produce for this Marxist
Utopia as opposed to the uh Market
mechanism and the price mechanism that
we are aware of today right um
that being said again the reason why
your question is so wonderful is because
I can see even as a deep anti-communist
the the the the the the interesting
intersections um marxists were very keen
on technology very few people remember
that um the original marxists and even
all the way up to the Soviet Union um
Marxist were very keen on technology and
so am I I guess the difference between
me and
marxists aside from the fact that I will
do everything in my life to oppose them
would be that uh I I I still believe
that the free market uh and and freedom
to to distribute um the the benefits of
a free economy as opposed to the
marxists who would like to probably
centrally Central plan everything well I
think we just figured out where super
abundance The Spectator and Marxism lap
which was a very nice note to end on
Maran thank you for joining us thank you
for having
[Music]
me